kseniya your characters very
street-smart how would you compare
yourself to her are you a street smart
or she's in real life
oh god no I'd be terrible I always say
what I admire about Kenzie is that she
can stare evil right in the face and no
matter how afraid she is she will stay
there you know for her friends she'll
fight to the end so I try to learn from
her I hope to be that brave and
courageous in my own life and street
smart I don't know I feel like if I was
if I had to live on the streets I'd be
like a total baby and and definitely not
as tough as she is Rachel your character
Tamsin questions her loyalties in the
show doesn't she tell us a little bit
more about that well Tamsin I think
struggles because she's a part of the
Dark Fae but in many ways has been
displaced from her original purpose and
I think you know we all sometimes
experience that in life and and it's
hard then to fully identify with who we
were before especially since she's now
Matt all of these lovely light Fae
people and and really you know I think
falls in love with Bo in a lot of ways
and so that sort of presents this this
huge problem for her and it's been
really interesting this season to sort
of see how that changes and evolves and
emanuelle your characters quite cunning
in the show how cunning would you say
you are in real life and what do you
think your character is saying about
talent agencies I think it's a lot of
fun being able to say and do
inappropriate things that normally in
real life you wouldn't be able to say or
do but you sometimes really want to and
and I think that's one of the the great
things about the Morgan and she's
unapologetic about who she is and how
she handles people and and I think you
know but yet she still has to manage
things and she doesn't show her cards
all at once she because she has to
manage too
you know the light Fae and all the
different characters that that she comes
into contact with and for her own
purposes and make sure that things go
her way questions about women it's just
talking about this because it is like
specialty girl power to be a part of it
and it's a challenge to find roles for
women that are strong and exciting and
challenging for us as actors so and also
don't depend like the the females in the
show don't get their identity from males
their characters aren't sort of dictated
by what the male characters in the show
are doing which is so rare it's really
dictated by what the female character in
the show is doing it I'm the voice of
women on the show there was a big fight
with the writers and we had a couple
guys on the set and we have we have a
mixed set of writers women and men that
write this show and we had a very
conservative writer for a little while
and he started writing scenes that
didn't make sense to me and we had this
big fight one day and all of a sudden my
whole office hears me yelling and
screaming in the opposite we had this
big fight about it it was fun but I sort
of developed this over the years I did a
show called
the original Nikita years ago I did a
show called relic hunter with Tia
Carrere which was fun and I've done a
couple films with women and just it's I
read Cosmo when I and I travel
constantly I'm on a plane every other
week sort of thing I used to read
women's magazines cuz I'd order I didn't
the girls magazines I learned advice
column stuff like that Cosmo advice and
did you ever write in for advice
yourself right in Cosmo no no
but I've actually written parts of the
show on the regular basis I wrote one
script but I've written like scenes you
know whenever I'm frustrated with
something I'll take it over all right
and where did Lost Girl come from silly
idea I had I was sitting in con and I
had the idea friend of mine actually had
pitched me a low-budget movie sort of
thing and I said no no I can make a
series out of this thing so and he had
pitched me a very weak idea shouldn't
say that way he didn't work right
and it was a genetically-engineered girl
who and I said and I decided she should
be bisexual because I wanted I said at
one point if Buffy were made today she'd
be bisexual and and I said she's got to
be strong she's got to be conflicted
between what's right and wrong and there
should be no rules for her life she
should determine their own rules and I
gave that general rule to a few people a
few people were challenged to write
something Michele Loretta came in she
found the character out and she put it
in the fav world it was great and it
just started going and going from there
but the idea was a very strong undefined
character and that she was gonna find
her way we adapted like mad to this cast
okay Ana who plays Beau originally was
the original character was a strong
woman who ripped doors off buses and was
determined and Ana had a certain naivety
in her own performance so we changed the
role to admit Ksenia she knows this her
role was originally fairly minor we
hadn't expected her to be what she
turned out to be so she was just a
little bit of us kid in the scene and
then she turned out to be a hero in a
big way because the way she did the
perform was supposed to be this quirky
character that came in once in a while
and just did some mean evil we called
her Cruella de Vil sort of things but
she but she really brought it all to
life so she's become a much bigger
character in the show and Rachael was my
what do I called you I said the angel
devil I said one that I said I wanted
this group I had this little dream of
this new character to introduce and I
said I want the face of an angel gonna
be our real [ __ ]
nothing and everybody said oh you'll
never find her you'll never find her so
it's been fun because these characters
have all been developed to sort of
improv wise I don't know if that's
worried but they evolved one of my
favorite scenes ever I actually I texted
your emailed your something right after
I saw that scene and I was like oh my
god you're comedic she know the back
stance yeah we were worried whether
she'd do it or not because it was but
you pull it off so beautiful well John
Fawcett called me and he was like okay
so there's this thing in the news scrim
is a yeah about like so am I supposed to
be a good dancer or is this like a bad
dancer and either way I'm gonna need
some help we're graphing what we're
gonna do so I don't look well
silly the point was to look but
choreographed so yes somewhat so we
talked about on the phone before
Christmas make sure the episode I'm just
after Christmas and and I remember being
up at like 4:00 in the morning because I
had like a 6:00 a.m. makeup call or
something doing this dance and I think
we set called like was like 7 a.m. by
the time I was dancing around it's like
oh my god probably crazy we have amazing
departments all around everything from
our set decoration to wardrobe to hair
makeup lighting David Green who
originated the lighting in the look of
the show is phenomenal and and I like
that we look different and we have a
very dark kind of shaded orangie Tuscan
I don't know how would you describe it
it's all right we have moods all the
time there's always these little smoke
machine not smoke steam whatever it is
fog after recess
although you can't even see the actors
on fire if you ever came to set you'd
see our lights aren't lights they're
this big and they're big square panels
that are like shaded with like so many
sets gives a really great look what
would you like to see happening in the
show in seasons coming ahead both for
your character and for the show as a
whole word you'd like to see it moving
forward Wow do you have any specifics
anybody because I know we took I can't
listen season 4 we made a little more
dramatic call call it's a terrible word
the writers hate when I say I want more
drama they say that's what we do J we
give you drama you know but we made a
little more dramatic
we somebody said take everything you
know about loss girl turn it upside down
we delve into the characters backstories
more in season four we tell people where
they all come from because we found that
the fans wanted to learn more about
everybody and so it's a lot more those
darker a little tougher season four I
have specific plans for future seasons
that have certain political messages
that I think are really important
because if you've noticed that Beau's
character doesn't like being sort of
branded named told what to do I think
that's going to be very important that
you know you shouldn't be judged by your
beliefs you shouldn't be judged by your
looks you should be judged by who you
are inside and that's going to be a big
part of the future seasons is there
anything that the network has said to
you you can't do
yeah we're very lucky this this show is
an unusual show and that oh god I gotta
sound really bad I have real control I
mean when this started the show
everybody thought I was out of my mind
so I couldn't find partners and the
Canadian Network really was involved
early but the way the show got bought
was unusual because the head of network
said I really don't get this genre much
and I had to say trust me and she'll
tell you the head of the network said
everywhere I go I told Jay said trust me
and I went I don't get this stuff it's
not something I totally understand so I
started said okay and the network's
involved very regularly but the only
thing they do is they've cut some of the
nudity down you know and they've jumped
on me a couple times for suggested
positions during sex scenes
I got an instruction once to take ten
seconds out of the sex scene and I that
was a note from the network I took out
two seconds and I went and said done you
know because they thought it was there
was a certain let's say how do I say
this there was a certain position they
didn't like not to do those positions
now that's the closest but there are a
few criticisms about the certain sex
scenes but that's the only thing you've
ever been know that's because in North
America sex is the illicit thing yeah
Europe it's totally different Europe
they're quite happy with lots of sex
less violence I mean any of it the
violence there's we got a little crazier
with the violence this year because I
think we've been tiptoeing around it and
as boh goes against bigger foes it had
to get a little stronger so I made and I
have this great stunt team that has done
major films and he had them reach a few
times as we broken a few things will
grow in a few sets this year so I think
so grating there's like there was real
some sets being crashed and stuff knows
I watched so much action sighs I'm not
bad in spot things done people are
watching
yeah it was it was a lot of fun too we
met up with the stunt people and and I
and sort of choreographed the whole
scene because you have to be able to do
all the movements so that they can film
that and anytime you know they sort of
see your face put you in and then put
the stunt girl in but then when it came
down to the day and we were rehearsing
it I said to Plato one of our stunt guys
Oh like I'd really like to do this and
so they let me do a bunch of it and I
think there's one winner Anna like
throws me against the wall and Anna and
I have this whole thing where we're
actually front and Friends in her life
when we hang out and we really like each
other and we have to like hate each
other in the show so she was like okay
I'm gonna put you against the wall I'm
so sorry for doing this I'm like who's
like BAM and then did ball breaks and I
was so excited with how it turned out
but yeah it was it was vicious
remember we improvised one scene her
hair was down during the fight it was
all loose so everybody came to me said
oh my god I've seen her hair what's up
damn what are we gonna do there's this
big debate about your hair me now so I
had them throw you over that table yeah
we'll just throw you over the table then
your hair will come down well just take
no no it has to happen for a reason so
there was this table with all this stuff
on there I walked over I said later when
I take my hair atoms that's such a great
scene Ksenia and Emmanuel I wondered
what your favorite bits of the show
we've seen so far are oh gosh well for
me I guess I mean in my scenes that I
that I've shot I the dancing step was
there's a lot of fun that was that was
sort of my equivalent I I don't really
get to do stuff I don't I don't exert my
yeah but the dancing was fun
I guess I
would have to be my favorite of the
shoes I have a lot of favorites but I
would have to say I'm really excited
about season 4 I got to do a lot of
things that were unexpected and I love
when we get to kind of bring our own
talents from life into the show like
I've gotten to play the drums time she
says something I get to do some cool
stuff and I'm I also love doing fight
stuff I'm always telling him like from
day one like more and more more so in
season three when I got to do the the
magic staff and and fight with the pig
that was grueling and intense but I
loved every minute of it and it was cool
to see it with the effects cuz you know
on the day you just have a little stick
and you're like okay well hopefully this
will look cool and then once the effects
and stuff were added on it was like oh
yeah
and look for her in season 4 because she
told me she wanted to do something about
a year ago or something I put it in it's
in season it's perfect it's amazing have
you got a plan through to the indices do
you have an yeah I have I've got a plan
well actually a lot of stuff that we've
adapted to be honest I mean we've been
sort of rewriting the show as we go
apt a lot to what's there but I have a
political message and I have an overall
story arc for the whole season and for
everybody's character yeah so no I have
somebody in Penn but I do make a point
and if you've seen we really give
important messages in the show on a
regular basis about empowering yourself
we had I think Anna and Zoe had a girl
come up to her once at a convention and
say I came out to my parents because of
your show it gave me the strength and I
had my parents watch your show so they
understood what it meant to be able to
freely enjoy choose what you want to do
with your life sort of things so but we
give big messages I mean we've done a
lot with Cassini's backstory about her
family and you'll see more of that
coming we still have to play with your
backstory but we've had some big
decisions that Tamsin's character had
them a face you've been a bit you know
just yeah this year we have some
complications to the Morgan's life but
we made a point in season for giving
back stories because and in the
backstories you're gonna see that
everybody has very complicated stories
and that the characters you're seeing
our mix of some very bad experience and
good experiences which is what
everybody's made up of right rumor has
it affects is back this year what are
your thoughts
doesn't go away yeah I don't think again
that was another character Beck's was it
supposed to be in two episodes in season
one he was supposed to die in the second
one but I loved so we brought him back
so yeah I think yeah we said he's back
but you know you can't kill vex I mean
vex is just too cool so he's around and
he's actually we are actually gonna
learn more about him this year too so we
get his backstory there's lots of
theories on the internet that Kenzi and
vex get together this season it's so
funny because I just recently heard that
drain interview and I was like what I
can't see if X is a relationship no I
think they have like a special bond I
mean they've been through hell and high
water together and it was nice when he
moved in with Kenzi and Bo and I love
having scenes with him and and I love
Paul but you know we'll we'll see season
for everything kind of gets flipped over
on its head
but I don't know about a Kenzi Beck's
future
you